[...]
SPEAKER 1: Casey Martin was a
professional golfer with a bad leg.
Due to a circulatory disorder, walking
the course for 18 holes of golf
was painful for Martin.
It even posed a serious risk
that he might fracture his leg.
Despite this disability,
he was an excellent golfer.
He asked the PGA, the
Professional Golfers' Association,
for permission to use a golf
cart during the tournaments.
The PGA said no.
Martin took his case to court.
He invoked a law requiring
that organizations
make reasonable accommodations
for people with disabilities
provided the accommodation
did not fundamentally
alter the nature of the activity.
Many of the great golfers of
the past testified in court
that walking the course was
an essential part of the game.
The case went all the way
to the US Supreme Court.
The Court ruled in Martin's favor.
They said he did have a right to
use a golf cart in the tournaments.
The Court ruled that the
essence of golf was the ability
to make shots, not the
ability to walk the course.
Critics argued that giving
Martin a right to ride in a golf
cart while competing in
professional tournaments
would be like giving a
disabled basketball player
who was a great shooter
the right to play
in the NBA while riding up and down
the court in a motorized scooter.
What do you think?
Do you agree with the
reasoning of the court
or with the reasoning of the critics?